let's go next to our caller from the
8:03 area code who is calling today from
8:03 hello David
hi who's this I watched videos about
Bolivia and Venezuela and I see that you
know you criticize what you call the
Leninist left and I've watched both you
and secular talk and you seem to have
different views about US intervention
there although you know you definitely
don't think the neocons so my question
is what are you thoughts on like
historical cases like the US
intervention in Chile at 1973 hours
yeah I'm against US intervention in
Latin America so what I I don't I don't
watch any other shows so what my
position is I'm against US intervention
in Bolivia and Venezuela what's Kyle's
position he's much more in defense of
the Venezuelan a Bolivian government
although he does have some very strong
criticism of Nicolas Maduro oh so and so
and he's against US intervention there
right yeah yeah okay yeah so am i all
right
do you think that Evo Morales was a
dictator no dictator is not the right
word but he certainly was not you know
he's not the strongest advocate for
democracy that Latin America has seen
let's put it that way all right thank
you all right thank you very much
appreciate the phone call let's take a
quick break if you're holding don't hang
up because I will go right back to the
phones after this very short break